I've been teaching about embedded
systems which is really you know little
micro processors and with those chips
and what you can do with them things
that go into smartphones things for the
blind things for sports but I really
fell in love with sports after I moved
to the cities I've been long wanting to
do something that combine both the
sports side as well as all the
technology and the other stuff that I
teach so for a while I've been wanting
to teach a course like this and with
some enthusiasm and backing from our
department and from students who wanted
to take it we decide offer this for the
first time and in fact we're the only
people who have such a course
information the cool thing that we did
this year was we actually had industry
speakers guest speakers that came out we
had Cisco come on Wilson football flew
up all the way out for this
NEP which is you know it's broadcast
trucking company that's located in
Pittsburgh
you know they gave us a facility tour
the Steelers game as a facility tour was
so cool for the students to see all this
behind the scenes technology that was
the best part we saw that there were a
lot of times when researchers were
putting accelerometers on two different
sports people and trying to find out how
things moved and what the way the people
moved and what you could learn from that
so what we decided to do was make one
platform that you could do all of those
things you could analyze any sport that
you wanted with at a very high frequency
very lightweight very cheap so you could
throw it anywhere you wanted and analyze
that way so this is the basically our
example that we made we basically have
our hockey stick and our sensor platform
this is just our prototype right now our
our eventual goal is to get it to about
a little less than a quarter of this
size and obviously without the giant
batteries but we can we go and take a
microSD card the same type that goes
into your cell phone we plug that in
turn it on to start recording they do
our hockey motion we can use skate
around you take a shot you go wherever
and do whatever you do with the normal
hockey stick we can record up to about
10 hours of data we actually were able
to get some better
information about if you shoot with a
hockey stick you see a really big spike
right when it hits the puck you can see
it the the rotation and how the player
moves the stick in their hand so it was
really interesting he said what we call
adaptive music player that music player
adapts according to you the tempo of the
speed that you're running at and the
reason that we set up this project
because it's because that we observe
that many people right now are putting
out their iPhone as a music player
during their jogging experience so we
thought that could be better if we can
create a more adaptive music player that
really adapts according to the context
of the jogger so that's basically the
idea the run is going to want to listen
to more like pop music sound the runner
got to run fast actually created impetus
for the runner to exercise so what we
have is a smart tennis racket and the
aim is for the racket to tell you by our
program whether you are getting the
racket properly or not
if hitting it in the sweet spot the
lasalle you hitting it and like matter
sweet spot is going to tell you it's
mainly for like beginners people who
haven't like you know play tennis before
just to get a feel like where they
should be hitting the racket and we hit
the racket in this region and you can
see here that we had a lot of spikes
over there and that correspond to over
to this over here so if you had hits in
the center of the racket it will give
you a green circle and if you had in the
corners of the racket it would give you
a red circle so we kind of hit them
between like a green and a red spot so
we had two circles turn to green on your
red and green is good red is bad and
we give a smiley face telling you
whether it's a good shot or a bad shot
so that was kind of like in between the
sports industry has lots of
opportunities for technology all the way
from the fan experience to rehab after
injury
everything gained a pregame day and when
you're training coaching scouting all
the way from when there are kids right
who start playing the first hockey game
all the way to professional so my hope
is that they go out into this industry
and they dominate because of the fact
that we've given them the engineering
skills to go do that my hope is that
they go out and maybe take over the
sports industry right there's a CMU alum
in with every one of these sports teams
these sports organizations giving people
good advice on technology our success is
in shaping their lives so they can go to
something cool with it